so we recently had this amazing woman on
our show her name is cheryl kohlberg
and she's a breast cancer survivor and
she's
on a mission to run a mile for the cause
and we actually raised a hundred
thousand dollars for her on this show
which is our biggest giveaway to date so
i'd really love for you guys to meet her
cheryl are you there can you say hi to
everyone
hi drew thanks for having me back on the
show it's so great to see you again
oh gosh thank you so much for coming
back on the show because
cheryl and i mean this in all the right
ways
you have possessed me
um i actually have a video i made for
you i'd like to show it to you
yeah perfect okay
i'm doing it got my water
got my mood ring and the pearls i hope i
can like
meet this challenge basically i want to
meet this challenge by october 31st i've
been walking
up to two or three miles a day just
walking i haven't started like intervals
of running yet
they say walking is even more important
than running all i want to do is walk
along the hudson i want to run
i want to run i am restless in my body
yay drew that's so exciting i'm so proud
of you
cheryl this is all for you it's all
about you
and it has translated into my own life
which i'm sure
was your intention so cheryl galvanized
all these people
across the country 50 for the cure and
she had all of these people your
intention was to run 50 miles in 50
states for your 50th birthday but
because of the pandemic
you had to change it and what you did is
you made everyone be able to get
involved
yes yes it's amazing on our facebook
page alone for the show people across
the country have really responded
they're freaking out
so we in honor of you everyone on the
show
is going to run or walk whatever their
capacity is
um a mile a day as you're doing 31 for
31 in october or
for me i'm just doing a mile by october
31st because i'm not a runner
but these are my shoes and in honor of
you
i am doing this one mile and the whole
show is gonna do it so
hey i'm so glad you hear that that's so
important
i can't tell you how much in the
possessing of me
you've made me want to move my body
be a healthier person you've put my mind
in a different mindset it is breast
cancer awareness month
but your story the way you designed your
mission the way you included everyone
it has swept me up and it's like
i'm compelled to the point i can't stop
by wearing your t-shirt so
for anyone at home who wants to join us
running club for a cause let's do this
go to our facebook page and share your
runs with our hashtag drew's running
club
for the show but it is all about you
cheryl you are such an
inspiration and i want to keep talking
to you
along the way this month in honor of
your journey and to keep you posted on
how i'm doing
that is so great thank you so much you
know one in eight women is diagnosed
with breast cancer so
just getting the word out there about
early detection
and raising money to find a cure we're
making such a great impact together so
i'm so happy that you're joining me on
this journey i got my mammogram
i got my mammogram this month um i'm
proud to say
because nobody was doing anything for
the pandemic so i went and got a
mammogram and
but you know really i'm just um i'm just
so inspired and i believe me a lot of
people are like walk on
i'll run a mile if you're not a runner
it's a thing
so join me
you